[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 10 juillet
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 60
18 26 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition c'est mon patrimoine
revient à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet c'est jusqu'à vendredi toute
cette semaine et des jeunes franciliens
qui ne partent pas en vacances
participent à un chantier de
restauration les vacances d'été viennent
de débuter une période clé pour les
professionnels du tourisme après une
hausse de la fréquentation l'an passé
comment s'annonce les mois de juillet et
août dans les hôtels nous poserons la
question à philippe un président de
l'umih 78 et puis c'est une animation
qui sent bon l'été justement remettait
tongs se déroule jusqu'à samedi à magny
les hameaux
cette année la municipalité vous propose
un voyage cosmique et puis invité aussi
de ce journal ludovic gauthier il est le
nouvel entraîneur de l'étoile sportive
de trappes c'est du football
elle met d'abord l'interpellation de dix
sept personnes hier dans les yvelines
série d'arrestations suite à une
violente bagarre survenue le 29 juin
dans le quartier du bel air à saint
germain en laye une centaine de
policiers avaient été mobilisés pour
cette opération est la rixe entre bandes
rivales avaient impliqué une trentaine
d'individus et fait trois blessés graves
la plupart des suspects interpellés hier
ont reconnu leur présence et
participation aux échauffourées
l enquête se poursuit auprès de la
sûreté départementale
l'opération c'est à mon patrimoine le
principe chaque année plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'enfants passent des
vacances au sein et des monuments du
patrimoine français
reportage dans un chantier de
restauration à la bergerie nationale à
rambouillet c'est avec marylène yapi
chine
qu'est ce qui serait un volontaire pour
commencer par bien brossé les joints
voit de nombreux volontaires sur ce
chantier spéciale au coeur de la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet
objectif de la semaine construire un
four à pain bah là je suis mélangé
l'intérêt clos elle est
pour que ça doit être ça devrait être
pas mal
ils sont douze enfants entre 8 et 11 ans
à venir de toute la france pour
participer à ce séjour dans le cadre de
l'opération c'est mon patrimoine
une semaine de vacances avec des
ateliers les activités sont plutôt très
rythmée sur sur la journée mais le décès
de leur faire faire une vraie activité
une vraie découverte de techniques
traditionnelles dont la construction
d'un four à pain au mortier de chaux à
la terre aux depuis l'eau et ils
apprennent ça tous au long de la semaine
la moitié d'entre eux participent pour
la deuxième fois charmé par une première
édition l'année dernière déjà dernière
dans les tentes a créé un rigolo ça fait
elle même
après on s'amuse on apprend des choses
plus loin activités sculpture sur pierre
elena s'applique sur sa tortue malgré
creuser et je suis en train de faire les
pattes ça d'abord tracé avec un truc
comme ça et après il faut retracer avec
un crayon comme ça à pierre ce soir ce
sera activités cuisine pour nos
apprentis artisans histoire de savoir
quoi mettre dans ce four à pain avant de
repartir chez leurs parents dans deux
jours mais dans l'actualité lue vs qui
maintient sa place dans les classements
internationaux l'université versailles
saint quentin apparaît toujours en
deuxième position mondiale des
établissements dans le domaine des
sciences de l'atmosphère palmarès établi
par le classement de shanghai est
publiée le 28 juin dernier lui véhicules
progressent également dans le top des
jeunes universités françaises du times
higher education elle atteint le
cinquième rang 1 de ce classement au
niveau national les vacances d'été ont
débuté pour de nombreuses familles de
france et du monde est une période de
repos pour certains un moment charnière
pour les professionnels du tourisme
après une fréquentation en hausse depuis
le début de l'année dans les yvelines
l'été 2010 9 sera-t-il aussi bonbons
pour en parler pour y répondre
philippe un bon soir soit vous êtes le
président de l'umih 78 c'est l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
des yvelines alors on est au tout début
de l'été et justement il ya le mois de
juin qui vient de se terminer ce qu'on
est sur un bon début pour cet été 2010 9
absolument le mois de juin est
traditionnellement bon dans l'hôtellerie
mais cette année il est encore meilleur
donc il ya une hausse de la
fréquentation toutes catégories
confondues et au niveau des prix aussi
c'est le chiffre d'affaires s'est un peu
mieux c'est à dire que le moral est bon
aujourd'hui chez les hôteliers y
retrouve un peu le moral parce que le
début d'année était pas très bon
justement entre janvier et mars
on a lui ressenti un peu dans les
yvelines les faits gilet jaune mais pas
trop mais quand même
alors à partir d'avril jusqu'à juin c
était une hausse et c'est pas mal mais
une reprise à bien sentir d'avril est ce
que ça veut dire que du coup les mois de
juillet les mois d'août s'annonce bien
ça ne veut rien dire pour une ans alors
le mode j'ai encore une fois est un mois
très fort mais le mois de juillet reste
stable et mois d'août aussi et
malheureusement ce ne sont pas des
chiffres très très important qui dit
qu'on a dans ces deux mois la même si
les perspectives sont un peu meilleures
mais c'est pas là on voit clairement
l'effet concurrence des plateformes en
ligne qui joue là pour la clientèle des
loisirs alors dans cet entretien
comment vous pouvez d'ailleurs mesuré
peut-être la fréquentation les outils
c'est quoi ces les réservations vous
avez une idée de quelle sera la
fréquentation des hôtels pendant louis
les hôtels ont quand même une visibilité
pour les mois de juillet août à ce que
les dés traditionnellement les les la
clientèle loisirs réserve prem en amont
en avance donc on a quand même une
petite perspective de ces deux mois même
si maintenant la tendance est aux aulas
minutes aux réservations de dernière
minute
excepté pour les familles où il quand
même il essaie d'avoir une d'organiser
leurs voyages
alors d'après des chiffres qui ont été
communiqués par yvelines tourisme l'été
2018 a été plutôt bon 4 165 mille
arrivées hôtelières enregistrées dans le
département avec une une hausse par
rapport à 2010 est ça va être compliqué
de répéter cette même tendance pour cet
été je pense que ça va être peut-être la
même mais pas plus je pense pas parce
que les histoires la visibilité n'est
pas très bonne et
[Musique]
et
les réservations sont pas quand même
rousset la montée en charge est pas
n'est pas là encore 63% pas remis de
cette clientèle qui est française ainsi
une clientèle davantage française il ya
un peu plus de mal à attirer les
étrangers vous parliez tout à l'heure
des mouvements sociaux les gilets jaunes
ça pue
ça pue nuira on va dire à l'attractivité
dans les hôtels dans les yvelines dans
paris oui
alors oui paris intra muros bien sûr
mais dans les yvelines non live les
faits pas été très significatifs je
pense que ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est
retrouver la clientèle étrangère c'est
vrai même dans les yvelines et la
clientèle française est toujours très
présente avec des vitrines forcément on
pense au château de versailles pas que
dans les yvelines ça c'est un point fort
en tout cas pour le département c'est un
point très fort c'est un point de départ
pour les yvelines le château de
versailles en général et on revient on
revoit appelé la clientèle asiatique et
la clientèle américaine est toujours là
italienne amérique du sud reviennent
petit à petit alors il ya un autre moyen
que vous en parliez tout à l'heure
philippin pour son séjour dans les
yvelines c'est de réserver par exemple
un airbnb des locations sur des courtes
durées vous étiez d'ailleurs venu en
parler dans ce journal de cette
concurrence avec les erp bi nbi
versailles avait pris une délibération
en ce sens pour encadrer ce type de
location est ce que c'est une
concurrence qui inquiète justement les
hôteliers a bien sûr pour la clientèle
loisirs et pouvoir maintenant même la
clientèle corporate dit business c'est
une sérieuse concurrence oui c'est
inquiète les hôteliers fortement et nous
voilà dans les premiers jours après le
14 juillet justement des réservations et
les week-ends ils sont beaucoup moins en
moins chargé et là on voit nettement la
la concurrence qui qui est en place mais
cet encadrement promis par versailles
avec cette délibération est ce que vous
en voyez les les conséquences
aujourd'hui ce que le sait-on cad re
mandé airbnb et est totalement appliquée
aujourd'hui oui on vous voit quelques
appartements qui sont remis en vente et
les propriétaires prennent un peu plus
de précautions avant de mettre en ligne
des annonces mais a toujours des abus il
a près de 70% des annonces à versailles
sur cette plateforme qui sont illégales
illégales sous la forme sur le fond donc
c'est à dire qu'il faut un numéro
d'enregistrement par la loi le maire
qu'il le dit l'article 51 de la loi élan
qui renforce les sanctions si on
respecte pas cette loi le maire de
l'obligation d'enregistrement des biens
meublés de tourisme voit quand même une
espèce de stagnation de l'offre mais
c'est très faible encore nokia toujours
vous disiez un motif d'inquiétude
oui il ya toujours un motif d'inquiétude
oui pour la clientèle loisirs alors on
le voit pas au mois de juin parce que
j'ai dénoncée moi très fort mais
lentement
je crois que les professionnels
commencent à le voir pour le mois de
juillet pour le mois d'août
surtout qui traînerait en général je
parle pour les hôtels urbains après les
hôtels qu'ils ont faim font du
département plus dans les zones vertes
entre guillemets ils ressentent un peu
moins ce problème là mais les hôtels
très urbain oui nord ils ont un peu
moins d'une minute ont résumé pour voilà
pour cet entretien comment se profile
l'été 2010 9 de l'été peau d'elisa se
profile pas trop mal malgré les
contraintes de sites et d'évoquer mais
il ya une bonne dynamique je pense qu'on
va espérer que que ça se passe bien mais
on pourra en reparler à la rentrée alors
c'est là qu'on vous recevra à nouveau
pour faire le bilan de cet été dans le
département merci philippe un jeu
rappelle fier d'être le président de
l'umih 78 c'est l'union des métiers et
des industries de l'hôtellerie 78 alors
que je perd actuellement mon oreillette
on va faire une petite pause économique
dans ce journal avec la découverte
d'oeufs à safran aircraft engines
l'entreprise est implantée à magny les
hameaux depuis 1990 et le site et est
spécialisée dans la maintenance est des
moteurs d'avions civils le reportage de
nicolas landry un moteur d'un airbus
a320 sur le poste de travail de josé et
thibault ces deux techniciens
aéronautique du site safran aircraft
engines de magny les hameaux font un
contrôle une inspection à l'intérieur de
la turbine du moteur grâce à un
endoscope
et à voir
une over température au niveau
beyblade de la turbine mais apparemment
elle est propre le contrôle se poursuit
aussi sur les différentes parties du
moteur donc ici à l'avant nous avons la
partie soufflante la partie soufflante
c'est le ventilateur en fait c'est lui
qui va aspirer l'air pour envoyer à
l'intérieur du compresseur en fait qui
est composé de la chambre de combustion
et du compresseur
donc c'est là que l'air va être comprimé
dans cette partie là
donc ce sont des plusieurs étages des
lettres qui vont se réduire et comprimer
l'air et qui vont l'amener dans la
chambre de combustion ici nous avons ici
donc la dernière partie est en fait
c'est cette partie là qui va entraîner
donc les bleds à l'avant et qui va faire
que le moteur va faire décoller l'avion
c'est ce qui va donner la puissance
démontage et remontage des moteurs
d'avion réparation nettoyage ou contrôle
de certaines pièces
le quotidien des 700 salariés de cette
usine implantée à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis 1990 pour démonter un
moteur à partir du moment où ils
arrivent chez nous jusqu'à la pièce
unitaire il faut compter une semaine une
grosse semaine ensuite vous avez les
opérations de lavage donc ça c'est trois
jours le contrôle une quinzaine de jours
puis leur montage qui fait qu'un moteur
est chez nous un peu plus de deux mois
airbus a380 boeing 737 max airbus a320
neo ou encore boeing 777
ce site reçoit près de quinze moteur par
mois directement en provenance des
compagnies aériennes on est plutôt en
croissance d'activité le trafic aérien
est en croissance importante et bien
nous embauchons en moyenne une
cinquantaine de personnes chaque année
principalement des moteurs aéronautiques
des contrôleurs aéronautique des
techniciens l'adaptation aux nouveaux
systèmes installés sur les moteurs
nouvelle génération le défi de demain
pour le site safran aircraft engines de
magny les hameaux
un mot de politique locale il réclame
plus de policiers nationaux pour sa
ville le maire divers gauche de
guyancourt françois morton a écrit au
préfet des yvelines à ce sujet une
volonté d'effectifs supplémentaires pour
faire face à une période estivale dit
compliqué les incivilités se sont
multipliées ces derniers jours au
quartier du pont du rotois et des saules
l'édile ne souhaite pas pour autant
augmenter le nombre de policiers
municipaux à aiguille en cours
le sport et du football trappe un nouvel
entraîneur un an après seulement sont
arrivées hicham 0,10 à quitter ses
fonctions pour raisons personnelles et
il est remplacé par vous ludovic
gauthier bonsoir bonsoir vous arrivé en
provenance de versailles où vous
officiez vous avez officiel à la tête de
l'équipe réserve pendant la saison
dernière et vous avez terminé d'ailleurs
la saison à la tête de la poule b de r3
une seule défaite est monté à la clients
en régionale 2 dans quel état d'esprit
vous arrivez vous à trappes
avec ce nouveau challenge déjà satisfait
de retrouver un club
vu la mésaventure qui m'est arrivé de ce
qu'on a on a décidé de mettre fin à
notre aventure exactement dans un
premier temps j'avais été confirmés dans
mes fonctions et au 20 juin
démis de mes fonctions donc c'est une
grosse satisfaction je remercie le club
de trappes de me faire confiance
eh ben je suis un éducateur ou un coach
satisfait heureux de reprendre trappe au
niveau où je devais évoluer avec le club
de versailles donc on espère faire une
belle saison aussi bien ça va être
difficile parce qu'il aime aussi avait
fait une saison extraordinaire avec une
seule défaite
mais on va s'attacher à bien travailler
dès la reprise au 12 août
on va parler des objectifs comment ça
s'est fait justement ce contact entre
vous et et le club de trappes est ce que
ça a été facile de vous convaincre de
rejoindre
on est très facile il n'y a pas eu de on
a parlé cinq minutes on s'est rapidement
mis d'accord voilà sur les objectifs du
club
sur l'avenir du club de trappes c'est un
club qui a envie d'être ambitieux dans
les années à venir
c'est ce que je recherchais donc
j'espère être à trappes pour plusieurs
années mais cette ambition qui vous a
attiré peut-être aussi l'opportunité
d'évoluer au même niveau qu avec
versailles exactement ça la division
aussi le niveau de l'équipe de trappes a
joué dans ma décision
c'est donc voilà je suis très satisfait
j'espère rester plusieurs années et on
n'est pas loin de versailles vous
connaissez aussi le coince j'imagine que
ça ça a joué aussi dans votre décision
de rester dans le même secteur
j'ai une petite fille dans ma vie de
famille j'habite pas très loin de la
ville de trappes donc c'était important
pour moi de rester dans le secteur
c'était une magnifique opportunité que
j'ai su saisir
on va s'attacher à bien la préparer
cette future saison
quand j'ai dit vous remplaciez chase et
redit qu'il ya eu finalement un parcours
similaire au vôtre il est arrivé il ya
un an une montée en r2 en terminant en
tête de la poule c de r3 une seule
défaite également comme vous à
versailles est-ce que vous connaissiez
est ce que vous le connaissez j'aime
bien on se connaît on sait quel regard
vous porter aussi sur la c'est une
saison exceptionnelle on s'est rencontré
sur un match amical cette année au mois
d'octobre novembre où le club de trappes
avait battu le club de versailles mais
on a eu des très bons rapports très
cordiaux
donc voilà je vais le voir cette semaine
pour qu'ils me rentre un peu plus dans
le détail avec les joueurs qu'il a
entraîné cette année mais mais voilà on
a des très bons rapports et ça va très
bien se passer pour la suite
qu'est ce qu'il y aura différents avec
vous sur le banc des trappes
il ya un style peut-être moi j'ai un jeu
de possession j'aime que mon équipe ait
le ballon mais après la qualité première
d'un éducateur c'est de s'adapter aux
joueurs que de trappes et là je suis en
train de les découvrir cette semaine
donc on va voir mais après c'est d'être
dans la continuité de ce qu'a fait
echems en essayant d'amener ma pas tout
voilà on ma petite touche personnelle
pour continuer à faire progresser
l'équipe que vous parliez tout à l'heure
des objectifs quels sont ils ces
objectifs fixés le président et le
directeur sportif arnaud m bézy monf
excellent maintien entre guillemets
facile à dire sans se mettre de pression
et d'être maintenu le plus rapidement
possible pour voir une fin de saison
tranquille dans l'urgence ou redescendre
alors si on regarde ailleurs ce groupe
d2r2 il ya des équipes réserves comme
poissy versailles que vous connaissez
bien
ivry-sur-seine des équipes premières
comme choisy-le-roi vivement qu'ils ont
déjà connu le niveau supérieur et val
d'europe qui redescend de r1 ça veut
dire que c'est très compliqué ça va être
diffusé au niveau de travail ça va être
une poule difficile après je pense qu'il
ya le club de huy aussi qu'on peut vite
que c'est un club qui a de l'ambition
pareil que trappe mais mais nous voilà à
prendre à chaque match on va bien se
préparer la semaine pour essayer de
gagner je suis un compétiteur comme tous
les coachs de la division entraîne ses
joueurs on les prépare la semaine pour
essayer de gagner le week-end près le
meilleur gagnera mais mais nous on fera
tout pour aller dit vous avez quitté
versailles qu'une certaine déception
commence à ce profil du coup ces
retrouvailles il y aura in your hands
animosité pleinement avec le président
s'est bien passé voilà ça manquait un
peu de franchise au niveau du directeur
sportif mais c'est le passé maintenant
on va s'appuyer sur l'avenir avec le
club de trappes
ou alors s'attacher à faire une bonne
saison on va parler d'avenir plutôt que
de passer moi j'ai passé une excellente
saison à faire ça je vais garder ce set
choses positives
non justement l'avenir avec quel
effectif est ce que ce sera un effectif
peu ou prou similaire est ce qu'il ya
des départs des arrivées qui sont
prévues il y aura des départs il y avait
quelques anciens dans l'effectif qu'ont
décidé d'arrêter avant ma nomination
c'était quoi qu'il arrive même si j'aime
bizarre bizarre rester en place six
années c'était acté déjà été actée donc
moi le meilleur recrutement c'est
d'essayer de garder un maximum de
joueurs de trappes vue au vu de leur
saison
après oui hein
je vais amener de l'extérieur dans vos
bagages peut-être quelques jours de
versailles 3 4 joueurs peut-être de
versailles et d'autres cas mais on aura
peut-être certainement un ou deux
versailles et en ce moment c'est des
rencontres justement les clés work y ait
des entretiens déposait cet effectif
exactement à voir leurs envies leurs
envies leurs ambitions maintenant avec
le nouveau coach avec moi ce qu'ils
attendent d'un coach aussi c'est
toujours important voilà moi ma première
et essaie de donner du plaisir à mes
joueurs la semaine voilà ils travaillent
à la journée donc au moins le soir à
l'entraînement qui va me prendre du
plaisir
on essaiera de s'attacher à tout ça avec
une reprise fixée au 12 août pour une
première journée de championnat le
dimanche 1er septembre est ce que c'est
pas un peu trop tard pour reprendre
trois semaines un peu plus la réalité
bien c'était un mois après on fait avec
les installations de la ville de trappes
d'accord nous les gens bien la
disposition de 12 août concentrera tous
les soirs de la semaine pour rattraper
notre retard et on sera prêt le 1er
septembre sans aucun doute et ça
ressemble à quoi une préparation du
physique forcément des matches amicaux
voilà c'est ça un peu de courses
beaucoup de ballons et on mettra en
application sur les entraînements on
mettra en application sa sur les matches
voilà on a quatre matches amicaux prévus
donc un par semaine
plus un une semaine à deux donc ça va le
faire
on vous souhaite quoi mme à la tête de
l'équipe de trappes de la réussite comme
j'ai pu en avoir avoir ça y est j'ai une
bonne étoile au dessus de ma tête je me
dis que je parte ça va continuer mais on
suivra votre saison avec attention merci
merci dominique gauthier vous est le
nouvel entraîneur de l'équipe fanion de
l'étoile sportive de trappes merci
d'être passé en plateau un mot de boxe à
présent après plus d'un an sans combat
faute de propositions intéressantes
ahmed el moussaoui sedan sera de retour
sur les rings ce samedi c'est à antibes
le boxeur de la dernière vient
d'apprendre qu'il remplacera est cédric
vitu blessé de dernière minute
il affrontera le russe alexander chanard
off qui compte 12 victoires en 17
combats ahmed el moussaoui sera lui
favori 1 dans cette affiche avec un
bilan de 29 victoires en 34 parties
mercredi jour de notre sortie dans les
salles du ces de cinéma du territoire
pour cette dernière de la saison c'est
le signer cet élan cours qui nous
présente sa programmation et c'est au
micro bien sûr de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
dans les salles cette semaine
aussi 17 une très jolie comédie
canadienne qui s'appelle la femme de mon
frère réalisé par monia chokri c'est son
premier film
elle est aussi actrice et elle est très
proche de l'univers et d'ailleurs du
personnage de xavier dolan alors très
rapidement c'est une histoire de famille
comme existerait réussit très bien joué
à 6 percutant avec une l'histoire d'une
fratrie en fait d'un frère et d'une
soeur qui vivent ensemble jusqu'à ce que
le frère rencontre une femme qui n'est
autre que la gynécologue de la soeur
tout ça au milieu d'une famille avec des
parents divorcés qui s'aiment encore et
qui vivent à proximité l'un des garages
votre dans la maison voilà je vous en
dis pas plus mais venez découvrir ce
film c'est vraiment une très belle
réussite
il a été très remarquée à cannes cette
année allait notamment avec une mention
du jury de la section un certain regard
le dans les salles si cette semaine
aussi 17 le très beau film de pedro
almodovar parle avec elle qui fait
partie du cycle que nous avons
organisées sur le cinéma très drôle de
va donc en version originale l'histoire
de deux hommes qui se retrouvent dans un
hôpital avec deux femmes qui se sont
plongées toutes les lampes basses et des
chirons c'est bouleversant et c'est à
voir
et enfin petite fierté et une grande
joie pour le signer cette nous avons
tenu cette année les trois label art et
essai c'est à dire jeune public
patrimoine répertoire et recherche et
découverte pour nous en sommes très
heureux
et vous pourrez en profiter dans nos
salles et enfin petite info nous restons
ouverts tout l'été avec tous trois
salles climatisées et vous souhaitons à
tous et à toutes
un très bel été 2019
[Musique]
et la commune d'achères a profité de
l'été pour lancer cette campagne choc la
commune a lancé une série d'affichés
vous la voyez à l'écran qui rappelle les
visuels des paquets de cigarettes
l'objectif c'est de rappeler cette
information la baignade est interdite
dans les temps débauche c'est là le 28
juin dernier qu'un jeune de 21 ans s'est
noyé elle était ce une période où les
noyades malheureusement à sont en
augmentation comment les éviter c'est la
question posée ce soir par le 7-8 débat
émission présentée par aurélie rond a
retrouvé après ce journal l'été soucier
un des moments positifs un avant goût
des vacances justement à magny les
hameaux la ville a lancé hier son 1/10
rtt remets tes tongs ces cinq jours
d'activités d'animations autour de
l'espace situé sur l'esplanade gérard
philipe le village accueille des enfants
et parents pour débuter cette période
estivale mélanie poker sensations fortes
pour des futurs astronautes pour les 50
ans des premiers pas sur la lune
magny les hameaux lui dédie ses rtt
depuis dix ans la ville propose une
semaine d'activités face à l'estaminet
on a décidé de fêter un peu cet
événement c'est vrai qu'il y a une
cinquantaine d'années tout le monde
pensait que dans cinquante ans plus tard
on serait revivrai tout sur la lune
c'est pas encore le cas donc bon ben
voilà on remet ça un petit peu au goût
du jour et puis ça change un peu des
traditionnelles fêtes que l'on fait
d'habitude
pour nous c'est essentiel de pouvoir
faire une petite jonction entre la fin
de l'école et puis on va dire le 14
juillet près 220 encadrants sont
présents sur le pas de tir création de
fusées structures gonflables des
trampolines les activités destinées aux
centres de loisirs et aux familles
tu as du jeu en particulier qui
m'intéresse oui la grande tour en avant
et pourquoi pas ce qu'on fait on s'est
tu et pour un prix aussi c'est bien
c'est bien on va franchement c'est bien
bon voilà pour commencer les vacances
hier on a fait
le cerf-volant on a fait l'avion là il a
tout les jeux en bois ils adorent ça
apparemment cette semaine c'est bien ils
sont pas encore tous partis en vacances
apparaît ça permet de nous écouter
remettez tong est prévu jusqu'au samedi
13 juillet un pique nique républicain
conclura ses rtt pourront profiter
il ne vous reste plus qu'à vous équiper
et puis cette opération connaît déjà du
succès et est en sable a débuté ce
week-end à montigny le bretonneux les
habitants de la commune sont accueillis
autour d'une plage de sable d'animation
et deux structures gonflables rendez
vous est fixé jusqu'au 18 août et c'est
encore mélanie poker qui vous en parle
c'était l'affluence des grands jours à
montigny le bretonneux pour le premier
week-end des grandes vacances c'était en
sable attire les foules
le sarde genre parce que j'adore la mer
donc c'est un avant goût des vacances et
ensuite l'ambiance c'était un animations
donc vos mesures c'est agréable
des fois après tu fais la queue sur nuit
on m'a après des voyages vers le jeu ou
à un grand toboggan après la précédente
pis il c'est avec la boue c'est c'était
trop bien on a trouvé que c'était une
très bonne idée de passer du temps à
l'été en sable et tous les ans et la
fidl le fait que ce soit voilà aussi
bien organisé c'est vrai qu'à pas mal
d'activités je regardais justement les
petits le petit programme donc c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment enfin c'est
plaisant voilà d'avoir autant
d'activités toboggans jeux d'eau lapin
géant et surtout la plage de sable
lésigny montain se sont donnés
rendez-vous accueilli par les huit
encadrants
ça permet aux personnes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de partir en vacance de
pouvoir s'adonner à des activités
estivales avoir un petit air de vacances
ça permet aussi de préparer ses vacances
quand on les a tardivement et de venir
régulièrement soirée puisqu'on est camou
vert jusqu'à 20 heures
les week-ends face à l'affluence des
années précédentes plus de 33000
personnes en 2018
la commune a fait le choix de réserver
l'entrée à ses administrés plus de 600
imminente ont inauguré le premier jour
des vacances
une affluence confirmé le dimanche voilà
ce sujet avec les images de mélanie
poker mais la voix était bien signé de
nicolas d'andry c'est la fin de 7,8
journal replay sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]